♪ ♪
>> Laura: LAST WEEK AND A
SERIES OF ANGLES I WARNED SENATE
REPUBLICANS THAT IF THEY DON'T
STEP UP AND VOCIFEROUSLY DEFEND
THIS PRESIDENT AGAINST THIS
ONGOING FARCE, DEMOCRATS WOULD
EXACT REVENGE ON THEM IF THEY
HAVEN'T FOR A BED WENT ON TO WIN
BIG IN 2020.
ON CUE "THE WASHINGTON POST"
REPORTED OVER THE WEEKEND THAT A
GROWING NUMBER OF G.O.P.
SENATORS CONSIDER ACKNOWLEDGING
TRUMP SINCE QUID PRO QUO ON
UKRAINE.
THE MEDIA, THEY ARE RUNNING WILD
WITH IT.
>> SOME SENATES ARE ON THE BRINK
OF PUBLICLY ADMITTING THAT THERE
WAS A YOU
WAS A UOU
WAS A UKRAINE QUID PRO QUO.
>> THEY'RE ARGUING FOR A SHIFT
IN STRATEGY, ACKNOWLEDGING THE
QUID PRO QUO, BUT INSISTING IT'S
NOT AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> IT'S THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AND
THEY'RE REALIZING THEY HAVE
NOWHERE ELSE TO GO EXCEPT FOR
ACKNOWLEDGING THERE WAS A QUID
PRO QUO.
>> Laura: HOLD ON.
JOINING ME NOW IS LINDSEY GRAHA
LINDSEY GRAHAM, CHAIRMAN OF THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
IS THIS TRUE AND IS THIS A
RHETORICAL ARGUMENT?
ASSUMING ALL OF YOUR FACTS NANCY
AND ADAM, ASSUMING IT'S TRUE,
IT'S STILL NOT IMPEACHABLE.
IS THAT IS WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> HERE IS WHAT YOU COULD TAKE,
THERE'S NOT ONE VOTE
IMPEACHMENT.
BASED ON THE PHONE CALL.
I DON'T BELIEVE MET ROMNEY WOULD
VOTE TO REMOVE THE PRESIDENT
OVER THE PHONE CALL.
ONE, HE DID NOTHING WRONG.
IF THAT'S AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE
YOU WON'T HAVE ANY PRESIDENTS
LEFT.
>> Laura: IN KENTUCKY TONIGHT,
A LOT OF KIDS HAD READ THE
TRANSCRIPT T-SHIRTS.
OF COURSE I READ A TRANSCRIPT!
YOU DON'T RESPECT ME.
>> IT WAS JUST TO GET YOU GOING.
THERE WAS NOTHING WRONG WITH
THAT PHONE CALL.
DID HE SAY, UNLESS TO
INVESTIGATE OPPONENT, DID HE SAY
THAT?
HAS ANYONE SAID THAT.
WHAT DID THE PRESIDENT SAY?
I DIDN'T TAKE THIS AS A QUID PRO
QUO.
WE DIDN'T CUT OFF AID AND
JOE BIDEN WASN'T INVESTIGATED.
>> Laura: RAND PAUL OF
KENTUCKY, HE WAS AT THIS RALLY
AND HE WAS PUSHING THE SENATE TO
BE STRONG.
WATCH.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS GREAT
COURAGE AND HE FACES DOWN THE
FAKE MEDIA EVERY DAY.
CONGRESS NEEDS TO STEP UP AND
HAVE EQUAL COURAGE TO DEFEND THE
PRESIDENT!
IF SCHIFF WILL NOT LET HUNTER
ABOUT INCOME AND IF YOU WILL NOT
BRING THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
FORWARD, EVERY REPUBLICAN SHOULD
TAKE A WALK AND SAY THIS IS A
FARCE.
>> Laura: IF YOU DON'T HAVE
THESE WITNESS HAS WALK OUT, WHAT
ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> I BELIEVE THE STATUTE HAS
BECOME A DANGEROUS TOOL ON THE
WRONG HANDS.
IT'S DESIGNED TO KEEP SOMEBODY
FROM BEING FIRED IF THEY REPORT
CORRUPTION.
IT WAS NEVER DESIGNED TO KEEP
SOMEBODY ANONYMOUS.
>> Laura: IT'S NOT IN THE
STATUTE ITSELF.
>> WITH ALL DUE RESPECT, YOU CAN
PROSECUTE SOMEBODY.
IMPEACHMENT IS THE POLITICAL
DEATH PENALTY BASED ON THE
ANONYMOUS SOURCE.
WE NEED THE WHISTLE-BLOWER'S
NAME DID WE NEED TO THEY ARE AND
THEY NEED TO BE CROSS-EXAMINED
UNDER OATH ABOUT ANY VICES THEY
MAY HAVE.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT WHETHER OR
NOT HUNTER BIDEN CORRUPTLY
ENGAGED IN LOBBYING.
DID JOE BIDEN ASKED THE
PROSECUTOR TO BE FIRED BECAUSE
HE WAS INVESTIGATING HIS SON?
JOHN SOLOMON HAS GIVEN US PLENTY
TO LOOK AT.
I HOPE CHAIRMAN, THE FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE CHAIRMAN WILL OPEN
UP AN INVESTIGATION ABOUT THE
ROLE OF THE STATE DEPARTMENT AND
ALL OF THIS.
>> Laura: THAT'S ALWAYS A
THORN IN THE SCIENCE OF
CONSERVATIVES BECAUSE THEY HAVE
A DIFFERENT WORLDVIEW AND
THEY'RE IN FOR LONG HAUL.
>> COMMUNICATIONS, THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THE COMPANY THAT HUNTER
BIDEN WAS SERVING AS A BOARD
MEMBER, THEY WENT TO THE
STATE DEPARTMENT AND SAID IF THE
PROSECUTOR DOESN'T LEAVE HUNTER
BIDEN ALONE, IT'S GOING TO HURT
US.
THAT TO ME IS A BOMBSHELL OF ALL
BOMBSHELLS WHICH SHOULD LEAD TO
A SENATE INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: HOW COULD HE NOT
CALL HIM?
>> THE MEMBER OF THE BOARD
ACTUALLY MET WITH JOHN KERRY.
>> Laura: LET'S MOVE ON TO
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THIS
WHISTLE-BLOWER FROM'S.
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER'S ATTORNEY
SAID WE WILL SUBMIT WRITTEN
ANSWERS SPREAD WHAT CAN BE WRONG
WITH WRITTEN ANSWERS?
>> IF YOU'RE IN CHARGE WITH THE
CRIME AND THE PERSON ACCUSING
YOU OF WRONGDOING, THEY DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO SAY I WILL
TAKE WRITTEN QUESTIONS.
YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO CONFRONT
YOUR ACCUSER AND THIS IDEA OF
SAYING THEY WILL TAKE WRITTEN
QUESTIONS VIOLATES EVERY NORM OF
DUE PROCESS.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF A REPUBLICAN
HAD DONE THIS WITH DEMOCRAT?
WE WOULD KEEP ANONYMOUS,
ACCUSING THE DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENT OF WRONGDOING AND THEY
SAID THEY WILL TAKE QUESTIONS OF
THE WHOLE TOWN WOULD BLOW UP.
>> Laura: DIDN'T TRUMP DO
WRITTEN QUESTIONS?
>> HE IS THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES AND THEY GRADE ON
WRITTEN QUESTIONS.
WHEN YOU ACCUSE SOMEBODY OF A
CRIME YOU CAN'T DO IT
ANONYMOUSLY.
YOU CAN'T GET A PARKING TICKET
BASED ON AN ANONYMOUS SOURCE.
>> Laura: PEOPLE FORGOT
SENATOR GRAHAM WAS AN
IMPEACHMENT MANAGER C BEEN DOWN
THIS ROAD.
ANY OTHER ADVICE FOR THE
SENATORS?
YOU WEREN'T IMPEACHMENT MANAGER
AND YOU GO AND PRESENT YOUR
POSITION.
THE SENATORS DON'T GET TO ASK
QUESTIONS, THEY JUST HAVE TO SIT
AND LISTEN.
>> YOU CAN ASK WRITTEN
QUESTIONS.
>> Laura: BUT YOU CAN'T
INTERRUPT THE IMPEACHMENT
MANAGER.
>> EVER IMPEACHMENT EXCEPT THIS
ONE WAS CONDUCTED BY OUTSIDE
COUNSEL.
ON THE ONE GUY THAT SAID
ROBERT MUELLER WASN'T ON A
WITCH HUNT.
I TOOK A LOT OF HEAT.
>> Laura: I THINK FROM ME.
>> I SAID I TRUST THE GUY TO DO
HIS JOB AND I INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION SAYING HE IT COULD
BE FIRED WITHOUT CAUSE.
ADAM SCHIFF ISN'T LOOKING FOR
THE TRUTH, JERRY NADLER IS NOT
LOOKING FOR THE TRUTH.
WHAT IS GOING ON IS A BUNCH OF
PARTISAN B.S.
EVERY REPUBLICAN SENATOR THAT
SIGNED ON MY RESOLUTION SANDY
PROCESS WASN'T FAIR, WE SHOULD
CONTINUE TO PROSECUTE THE PEOPLE
PROSECUTE ANY PRESIDENT.
WE SHOULD LET EVERY AMERICAN
KNOW THIS IS THE FIRST TIME IN
HISTORY ANYONE HAS EVER BEEN
IMPEACHED BY PARTISAN END.
IF YOU THINK ADAM SCHIFF IS OUT
TO GET THE TRUTH, YOU SHOULDN'T
BE ANY SENATE.